Right now, as you’re listening to this,
you are being robbed.
A chunk of everything your hard work creates
is being stolen from you.
And it’s a system called capitalism that’s
robbing you.
Every day, when you check in to work for your
boss, you are being taken advantage of and
stolen from.
You are being deprived of the full value of
what you contribute.
Let me break it down.
A capitalist isn’t someone in a top hat
burning library books to run a misery factory.
Anyone who puts forward capital – money
– to set workers in motion becomes a capitalist,
that is to say, they’re acting as a capitalist.
And what’s their goal?
People will tell you it’s innovation, or
competition, but down in the real world it’s
pretty simple: capitalists have one goal.
And that goal is to turn a profit.
Pursuing profits to accumulate money is just
how capitalism works.
That’s the nature of the beast.
It’s the single impulse of capitalism.
That doesn’t make capitalists personally
greedy, though some might be.
We’re not even talking about good or evil
here: capitalists need to maximize profit,
to the exclusion of all other considerations,
or they’ll get eaten up by capitalists who
are smarter or more ruthless than them.
That’s the jungle law of the market.
So capitalists need profit to survive.
But where does this profit come from?
That’s where you come in.
Literally.
Profit comes from YOU.
Here’s a little thought experiment.
Meet Harold.
Harold has a chain of buildings full of kitchens
full of ingredients.
But Harold doesn’t know how to make a burger
himself.
How does Harold get someone to make enough
burgers that he can sell them and turn a profit?
It’s not a trick question – he pays you!
Because you know how to make really good burgers.
The money he uses to pay you is what we call
“capital.”
That’s money used to set production into
motion.
Let’s say Harold spent $1,000 buying all
the ingredients in the restaurant, and after
you work for a few weeks there, turning the
ingredients into burgers, they brought in
$3,000.
That’s not bad!
You added $2,000 worth of value to the ingredients.
But wait.
You don’t get all the money.
Because Harold now has $3,000 on his hands.
$1,000 of that is just making up for the cost
of the ingredients.
And if you were paid for the full value of
your labor, you’d be making $2,000.
But then Harold would only be breaking even
on the burgers.
And he needs to make a profit in order to
survive.
So Harold decides NOT to pay you for the full
value of your labor.
Maybe he pays you just $1,000 of the value
you produced.
Maybe he pays you $1,500.
No matter what, you’ve been stolen from.
You spent more of your labor than you were
compensated for.
But here’s the dirty truth: the story doesn’t
end with you and Harold.
This process plays out across your city or
town, your state, the country and the entire
world – the rich get richer and the little
guy barely gets by.
We call the process - a boss’s stealing
from you - “exploitation.”
We don’t mean that in an emotional sense
about how we feel about it, but something
that’s actually a documented economic phenomenon
– the gap between how much the worker produces
and how much they get paid.
Exploitation is a universal feature of capitalist
economies.
And it never ends: the system requires more
and more exploitation – paying workers less,
making them work more, or making them more
productive without increasing wages.
When you see in the newspaper that a corporation’s
recording record profits, that is what they
are doing: your hard work is producing more
value, but you’re not getting enough compensation
in return.
There are tens of thousands of Harolds out
there.
But billions of people just like you.
You and Harold are two different types of
people.
You belong to two different classes.
There’s a capitalist who owns the means
to produce goods and services, and there’s
workers who only have their own labor to survive
on.
The capitalists appropriate the value that
the worker’s labor creates and keeps it
for themselves.
And you are not immune from it.
At any job you work at, the condition of your
employment is that you produce more by your
labor than you get paid.
So in the capitalist system, no one is paid
what they’re worth.
Capitalism means they get paid significantly
less.
All profit is value extraction.
And that means that all profit is theft -- from
you.
This is Richard Wolff, professor of economics
at the New School and founder of Democracy
at Work, for the Gravel Institute.